The true power of UI
router is in nested views.
Let's add a nested view
to the items detail page.
Let's add a state to see an item's
reviews and one for its nutrition facts.
To add a nested view,
we need the same name as the main view
that this one will be nested inside.
So that's item.
Then we need a dot and
then it's the nested views name.
We need to generate both
of these templates.
But we don't need controllers because
they'll just inherit the item's data
from the parent route scope.
Here's what we have for the nutrition
template and over here is the one for
the reviews.
See that for the reviews template uses
an entry repeat directed to loop through
all the reviews.
Lastly, I added some reviews
to the item JSON file so
that they'll have something to display.
So UI router knows of the nested
item and the templates to use.
We need to tell UI router where we
want these views to appear though.
We need the UI view directive again.
But since we want them to
display on an items page,
we need to add it to our item.html.
Finally, we need to create a link for
each view,
and we now have nested routing.
Nested views in at management can
be very complex and complicated.
UI Router makes this
incredibly easy though.